MEETING
NO SCORE TAPS IT AHEAD.
HE HAS BEEN A REVELATION
SO WHEN HE GOES WIDE, THERE IS
NO WAYPOWER-PLAY
SHE YEAR AT 8:53 IN THE THEM SO
HE'S GOT A LITTLE BIT MORE MEAN
THEM GOING FORWARD HE JUST
HE CIRCLES THE GOAL.
OUT HIGH NOWY BY TYSON BARRIE W
RECOGNIZES THAT NUGENT-HOPKINS
IS FLYING A THIRD MEMBER OF
THAT TRIO DOWN THE
DARNELL NURSE, HE'S A BIG LAD.
I THOUGHT IT COULD'VE
HE GOT WIPED OUT AS THE SHOCK
GOT BLOCK.
BACK ON THE ER IT.
HE JUST DUMPS UP BY
CONNER McDAVID.
SLIDES IT BACK GO IN THE
SECOND AS BARRIE FLOATS IT INTO
THEE BY
HE HAD THE NUMBERS, PERHAPS..
A GOOD PLAY IN THE NEUTRAL INE.
HYMEN YORK.
ZACH ASHTON-REESE HAS HIS FIRST
DIVI
BRASSARD IS PARKED IN F F.
THAT MAY HAVE GONE FROM ANIMAL
FOOT HITS.LOT DRYSDALE SAVE MAD
SMITH.
GIBSON LEADS FOR FOWLER.
6:45 TO GO.
McLEODOD OVER
GIBSON OFF OF THE LINE.
AND DATE GOOD SAVE.
IT GOT THROUGH   A, I THINK HIS
TEAMMATES ARE A LITTLE LITTLE
MORE RELAXED.